marks on you mark jump ah no no no no no
man oh it's horrible teamwork okay wait
what the hell yeah well whoa whoa whoa
oh my god I'm playing against myself
here well there we go
oh no no who do I want to win and
playing balls game no no oh no okay Oh
God go for it
you have to do it I'm responsible I
responsible for your own defeat here son
okay oh I got it pretty much just
whatever sit wait wait go that's too far
away oh you get it go
say any goal oh what'd you guys do I'm
out I'm Audi I'm going into the goal
okay bye no no you go over there yeah do
that do that
what give me partly haha
okay well you got it girl everyone's on
mice ready oh my god the hell oh you
guys got a push middle cuz it's like I
didn't know what to do okay so I'll play
offense do you want to play my goalie
mark yes it seems like giving up a lot
oh wait do I switch sponsor me no I got
here I'll just play yeah we got I'll
play is it deep
no I'll play the goalies okay as I said
the cream anti-god gonna be off-camera I
got alright you're holding hands
practically ready I'm being our goalies
whoa
oh my god Oh God
bob is not a [ __ ] me you got lime up in
the car I play with myself
ah okay we got it
I don't know who team oh I forgot the
gold oh oh gee I don't know my own
stream yeah back in the game oh [ __ ] I'm
not biased or a little bit blue seal of
me winning crap Oh God - its - its power
to her drop - okay now wait you and I
are a team okay so it's just me yeah
that's not good little remiss okay go I
got me shot on camera okay Who am I
again
oh okay oh no no joke you guys just go
on yourself oh wow okay oh yeah yeah
oh yeah well son love hitch gonna be a
poor sport there mm-hmm oh no no no no
no you got that oh no guys guys Oh same
team what the guys same team spread out
oh [ __ ] you playing defense yes I'm not
moving unless I have uh-huh
wait good oh yeah there we go here we go
oh god no I got that's the stretch can I
move in oh my god
all right there's one
haha inserted wait Oh guys no roll okay
stay like this wha
no [ __ ] you Oh stay like this bug oh
look um you got make a very problem you
guys get out of there fine you guys get
out of there no stay no stay
try it okay still oh no no no no okay
guys you guys get out in there look at
this [ __ ] get out of there you get
out of there are we supposed to do good
that's you I'm who's the other results
all right now you score on yourself no
no no no we got Heat come on Bob's team
no kid you know you're off it I'll be
going okay dad yeah that'll do okay our
guy hey all right
yeah no no oh wow welcome yeah okay no
yes I was too excited I hope the
shopping good defense wait whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa okay okay I guess I'm out
here now wait what why I'm here oh no oh
god whoa he's really bad by himself it's
hard to control disease Epperly D not
get over here thank you I got it [ __ ]
you
What evil I mean this is what oh my god
I got I'm gonna hold waiting the goal
you keep going yeah I got it no I got go
way to get me there so yeah
I got it okay you saying are you better
start I'm gone oh oh gosh I'm stuck I'm
gonna do the lily stuff okay gosh oh my
gosh little more kick him in the neck oh
I got oh God
yeah I got ya oh yeah okay
this way good after everything going to
go go on the all dammit hmm oh okay boo
[ __ ] me today mother you were fine oh
yes I buried my favorite Oh God
okay I think I'm undefeated of this one
maybe it's maybe it is luck and okay
what should we do that one whoa all
right it's easy for getting in this way
Oh whoo Oh coming a cop stuck again
Jesus with this thing get off no you're
not me oh no I got a fair shot okay
all right got it God get off of me truck
haha okay I am stuck damn it hey whoo oh
yeah yeah you just do that my god you go
nuts
ah no oh my god no all right get behind
me then that's good I just I mean no no
no yeah I'm getting tied your defense
wait a game you know you just do
whatever you want wait okay nobody stop
what are you doing you know you're gay I
don't know all right everyone Macintosh
it - oh well god either team is over
you're saying you're scoring board or
not what are you doing to me right now
but we got a new defense oh yeah
Oh God
oh my god clang both insect okay
God guys want us to be left up to me
okay no no shell well okay all right
that was a suggestive no no wait up it's
I didn't meet I don't mean to wait I
would like you to win just so much as I
would
whoa oh yeah yes cocaine Oh Who am I be
cool be cool because I'm done nothing it
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa okay
tickle take it easy guys take it easy
fellas you're tired
ah pop oh jesus oh violet
it's funny what Oh guys are just like
[ __ ] that other dude talkers look well
Turin no jump like definitely jump with
a score we're on it score mark my what
I'm doing is go for it you got it
constraining places slow God dang it
whoa yeah oh [ __ ] that nice kick there
Bob whoa whoa okay Oh get it gotta get
Bob ooh you got it oh god mark all over
this no no I got this that guy's just
dead I can't get that guy up there you
know come on I got I'm really I'm going
score yourself ah ah [ __ ] I can't get
[ __ ] balls you that was your fault
I don't know I know I know all right
mark but wait what oh I didn't I didn't
knew that one as well
yeah well I press bolt at the same time
to see what happens Oh Pat yep
no no no I'm stuck on your face Oh is
always benefit you guys go for it uh
it's all you wait all you wait yeah good
good just kick it as hard as you can
nobody go through six hours of this crap
when I come back for another night
started talking and then you started all
over the hottest yeah okay all right